rookin lake in India is 16,000 feet
above sea level
it's a glacial lake and it is
overflowing with skeletal remains but
the real amazing thing about skeleton
lake is what killed the people that are
there so in 1942 this Indian forest
ranger stumbles across route connect and
sees that it is full of skeletons it's
full of the remains of hundreds of
people looking back up through the
through the frozen ice in this lake it
would have been a an absolutely
terrifying sight so this forest ranger
became concerned that these might be
Japanese soldiers as part of some kind
of World War 2 maneuver and reported it
to the British but on a follow-up study
in the 1950s they found these skeletons
were in fact much older than that even
after this forest ranger discovered them
they don't know how they got there they
don't know what killed these hundreds of
people dozens of theories put out
ancient soldiers a caravan of merchants
royal wedding party maybe they died of
disease they all are froze to death this
mystery goes unsolved for decades there
were some songs and stories that were
told that lent some possible explanation
to how these people came to be there and
what killed them in 2005 as part of a
National Geographic expedition begin
examining the skeletons and they find
some interesting things one it's a mixed
group there are women there are children
there are older people they think they
may have been on their way to festival
celebrating non Madhavi all of these
skeletons suffer from similar wounds
blows to the heads and shoulders with a
blunt object
this area of India because it's in the
mountains because in the Himalayas
16,000 feet above sea level it's over a
glacial pass the weather is out of
control
the area is also known for extreme hail
storms and that is what killed all of
these people the
and folklore we're about the goddess
nanda Davi becoming angry at a traveling
party an act of rage
cast down stones as hard as iron
striking all of these people dead and
all of the scientific evidence all of
the forensic evidence backs this up
they were killed when a freak hailstorm
started dropping hailstones that were as
big as 9 inches in diameter that is what
killed the people at skeleton like a
frickin hailstorm so well it may have
taken until 2005 to definitively prove
with science that the people the
hundreds of people who had been killed
at rookin were killed in a freak
hailstorm the stories the songs of the
area have been telling this tale for
over 1,100 years
subscribe here and watch more videos
here people steal the skeletons they are
slowly being taken the region is trying
to get the area earmarks designated as a
protected region we even leave them in
the lake skeleton lake so that it's
named after them leave them there